[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVREN ERYUREK: Good afternoon.
How's everyone doing?
AUDIENCE: Great.
EVREN ERYUREK: Nice.
It's 2 o'clock,
we're ready, right?
My name is Evren.
I'm the director of product
management and data analytics
organization in Google Cloud.
And today I have
my guest, Michelle.
She'll join us in a few seconds.
If you want, you can
come up here too.
And today's topic is data
governance in this world.
And we've got a lot of
questions yesterday.
Even during my presentation for
streaming analytics, one of you
have asked--
I think you're there, thank you.
I love that topic.
This is something we're
going to talk about probably
at length over the years.
But I wanted to start what
we're going to discuss today.
And Michelle is going to cover
a lot of insight for you guys.
I'm really excited to
have her here with us.
And we're going to talk about
what data governance is,
what companies are doing.
In the end.
I'm going to a little
cover about what
we're doing on Google Cloud
to help you really deal
with your world and how these
things can be actually enabling
capabilities to grow
your businesses.
So let's talk about data.
Data is getting
bigger and bigger.
I think I mentioned
this yesterday, too.
By 2020, every one of us
in the world, every second
will produce about two
megabits of data every second.
That's a lot of data.
Sum them up-- there is
about 8 billion of us.
That's quite a bit of them.
MICHELE GOETZ:
That's a lot of data.
EVREN ERYUREK: Look at all those
things that we're seeing today.
There are businesses
being built around us,
but still we're
scratching the surface
of what we can do with data.
Either we are not ready,
either we're afraid of it,
or we don't have the
right tools for it.
Who remembers the
Vs of the big data?
Remember, velocity,
variety, volume.
Those three things are still
kicking really, really high.
Take a look at the volume
and variety, it's tripling.
Fantastic for us because
you can take this data
and generate some great
insights for your businesses.
But if you're not
prepared to deal with it,
that won't help you.
Look at the velocity, it
is shaping up immensely.
Yesterday, we talked
about streaming.
And I had a partner
on stage with me,
AB tested, they were talking
about how they were utilizing
this real-time data to generate
revenues for their customers.
You can do the same
if you can harness
how you can use the data,
if you can turn governance
into revenue generating
mechanism for yourself.
We are seeing
businesses building data
and event-driven
structures for themselves.
You can do the same.
We have the platform for you,
we have the means for you.
There are a lot of things
that we're learning.
But I said, we're not
really using all the data
available to enhance.
Take a look at this, only
1% of the unstructured data
is in use.
Only 1%.
If you look at the 50%
of the structured data
is still sitting and not being
used for decision-making.
We're leaving it, we're
leaving value behind us.
What will it take for
us to really get there?
I think all of us know why
we can't do this, right?
It's complex.
MICHELE GOETZ: It's super hard.
EVREN ERYUREK: Data is
distributed everywhere,
loss of legacy
applications, silos,
we may not have the talent.
But there is still a way.
What do you think?
MICHELE GOETZ: Well, we
have to address people.
EVREN ERYUREK:
What do you think?
MICHELE GOETZ: I know.
We have to address people.
What do we really want?
We want to be able
to use it, we want
to be able to
interact with it, we
want to be able to
play with our data.
But our experience around
our data is really--
we struggle with it.
We struggle with it
on a small data scale.
And if we struggle
with it there,
we're going to struggle
with it on a big data scale.
Who owns the data?
EVREN ERYUREK: All
right, some guesses.
It has to be interactive.
Who owns the data?
MICHELE GOETZ:
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
generated it.
EVREN ERYUREK: Good, all
right, that's one way.
AUDIENCE: Collectors.
EVREN ERYUREK: Collectors, OK.
Do you own your data?
MICHELE GOETZ: No.
AUDIENCE: The company
owns the data.
EVREN ERYUREK:
Company owns the data.
MICHELE GOETZ: These
are way better answers
than what I usually get.
EVREN ERYUREK: That's good, see.
MICHELE GOETZ: We have
smart Googlers in the room.
A few years ago
we started asking
the question, who
owns the data, looking
at it through the lens of saying
where's the data strategy sit,
where does governance
sit, where does master
data management sit-- all things
that help us better understand
and take advantage of our
information to make decisions,
to grow our revenues, to
great customer experiences.
And data decision-makers,
what do they say?
IT owns it, 50% of them.
IT, take care of it.
EVREN ERYUREK: Who's
in charge here?
Do you own the data?
AUDIENCE: No.
MICHELE GOETZ: Do you
want to own the data?
AUDIENCE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHELE GOETZ: No.
EVREN ERYUREK: Great, great.
MICHELE GOETZ: So what do we do?
So that was back in 2015.
In 2018, we asked
the question again.
And what did the data
decision-makers say?
They said, IT still owns
it, and more of them
said that IT owns it.
So what does that actually mean?
You said who created it,
where does it come from,
who's taking care of it.
And it really
boils down to this.
I want my data to work.
Stop frustrating me every
time I go into my application,
every time I go into my
business intelligence,
every time I'm trying
to run analytics,
every time I'm just
trying to figure out
who my customer is so I
can have a grand old party.
EVREN ERYUREK: Don't
lock your data.
MICHELE GOETZ: Don't lock it up.
EVREN ERYUREK: Make
it work for you.
MICHELE GOETZ: Make
And when they talk about
or when our respondents
talked about IT
owns the data, it's
because the complexity
of it is a nightmare.
It's what we deal
with every day.
We need to simplify it.
So what we're going to do is now
take this to data governance,
because data governance
really is that accelerator
to make it happen.
Do you believe that?
EVREN ERYUREK: And
she will convince
you guys how data
governance is an accelerator
for the business.
MICHELE GOETZ: Accelerator.
So let's introduce you
to data governance first.
EVREN ERYUREK: There we go.
So if you look at data
governance, little history.
If you go back, some
of you are coming
from the very highly regulated
industries back in 2007.
It was specific to the
departments, very specific.
In 2008, if you
remember, there was
this crisis, lots of regulation
around the financial data.
What can be done, who can
be done, very prescriptive.
Remember those days?
Things have changed.
But if you look at
today where we are,
GDPR happened in Europe.
In here, CCPA is happening.
Don't be afraid of it.
It's actually going to help you
make more sense from your data.
What's driving the
governance in the data
governance in the initiatives?
MICHELE GOETZ: We want to
connect to our customers,
see who they are,
get a customer 360.
We want to control our
data, protect ourselves,
stay in compliance.
We know that our
regulators look at how
we use data and the type of
data that we're collecting
to say how we're doing.
We just don't feel
like we're in control.
It's that make that
data work thing.
EVREN ERYUREK: Exactly.
MICHELE GOETZ: If we don't
have great experiences,
how can we trust our
information to make decisions.
EVREN ERYUREK: Every
one of them are actually
asking about these things.
The complexity of the
data, lack of control--
that's old, maybe the
perception of control--
and how we can actually
operate and drive efficiencies
around it and risk management.
These are all items that are
driving the governance needs.
Now it is about policy,
it's about people,
it's about technology.
Now you might say, hey, I heard
the same thing for other things
too, but it's absolutely true.
But there are specific
cases that we can actually
leverage and build
together to really make
this thing work for you.
It is going to be
driving the success.
MICHELE GOETZ: Right.
EVREN ERYUREK: How
does it come to rescue?
MICHELE GOETZ: How does
it come to the rescue?
Well, data governance is
like any other competency
in our practice in our business.
People, process, technology.
Sounds really boring
on the surface of it,
but it's that brain trust
that comes together.
Where not only are you trying
to drive down the complexity,
whether you're trying
to mitigate risk,
but on the other hand
we do have strategies
of getting value from our data.
And we need policies that
enable us to democratize it
and to find those
great insights.
And so when we talk
about data governance
as that starting
point for that value
in accelerating our
business forward,
that's how we should really be
thinking about our governance
program, as a
strategic competency.
It's not just--
EVREN ERYUREK: Have you
seen examples of how
people operationalized it?
MICHELE GOETZ: Oh, yeah.
EVREN ERYUREK: Is it lowball?
MICHELE GOETZ: Yeah,
it's a lowball.
Thank you.
EVREN ERYUREK: You're welcome.
Who does this thing
well these days?
MICHELE GOETZ: So I
think John Deere has done
some really interesting things.
EVREN ERYUREK: Anyone in
here in the world of where
John Deere is similar to?
Some manufacturing, operations?
MICHELE GOETZ: Farming.
EVREN ERYUREK: Well, maybe
they'll take advantage.
MICHELE GOETZ: All right.
Let's tell a little bit
of story about this.
Just like every
other company here,
all of you here
governance is a nightmare.
And when we've
started on big data
and predictive and
prescriptive analytics,
we don't want anything
getting in our way.
So what do we do?
We grab the data we need,
and we start analyzing
it and we build insights.
This is what John Deere
was really focused on.
How do we help farming
communities drive better crop
yields?
How do we better manage the
finances around crop insurance,
for example.
And so they were just grabbing
all of this IoT data off
of their tractors, watching how
those tractors were operating
in the fields, how the seeds
and the fertilizer was going,
how the harvesting was
happening, relating this
all back to their customers and
the finances to support this,
as well as the
dealerships who are
helping with a lot of the
fixes on the equipment.
What happened, though?
They ran into a problem.
They weren't thinking
about governance,
they weren't thinking
about what is the org
structure of themselves
in order to relate back
to their customers
and dealerships.
They didn't have
the proper master
data around their customers
and their dealerships.
So you can think
about how do you
create all these
relationships, and really
understand what
information can I share
or should I share with whom.
There are things
that agronomists
don't want to share
with the dealerships,
or they don't want to
share with their banks.
It's very personal.
And when you move
equipment around
in big farming
areas, what happens?
They don't just tractor
down the street.
EVREN ERYUREK: It's a nightmare.
MICHELE GOETZ: You're not always
stuck behind the International
Harvester.
Sometimes they're put on
flat beds and they move.
What happens when you
move that tractor 50 miles
and you're trying to figure
out how your harvest is going?
That's a problem.
So a lot of data quality issues
were starting to come up.
So what they really
did is they took a look
at how they were moving
forward very quickly.
They were running a DevOps
agile development practice,
not thinking about
governance as requirements.
Now they start to bring
those business requirements
in that really drive the
policies, the understanding
about who their customers are,
who their dealerships are,
who they are as an
org, understanding
how their equipment runs.
And it's not just this control
thing that drives you away,
but it actually brings
the value back in.
And so rather than
struggling for another year
with these practices,
they're able to really drive
forward very, very quickly
because the information is
trusted and the value of the
insights really comes together.
EVREN ERYUREK: Absolutely.
This is why we wanted to share
some of these examples with you
early on because if you're on
this path and start actually
looking at it, down the road
you'll start seeing, hey,
we didn't really
think about these.
It's best to really consider
what we need to do collectively
as you're building your
operations around data,
around events and what you
want to do around big data,
because governance is
going to be your guide.
Your governance is
going to be your help.
It's going to be
there to really help
you accelerate some
of the things that
are coming in your
way that you may not
be considering it today.
MICHELE GOETZ: So how do
you start to look at this?
Well, you want to have
a vision for the future.
You want a success story.
EVREN ERYUREK: Absolutely.
MICHELE GOETZ: You want to
know what success looks like.
So let's connect the dots
between what information
that we have.
EVREN ERYUREK: Does it
matter which industry,
the other industry?
MICHELE GOETZ: No difference.
EVREN ERYUREK: No difference.
EVREN ERYUREK: So they may
not be the farmers in here.
MICHELE GOETZ: You don't
have to be a farmer.
EVREN ERYUREK: OK, good.
MICHELE GOETZ: You don't
have to be a mechanic.
You don't have to
be an engineer.
You can be all of those things.
EVREN ERYUREK: But they have
supply chains, some of them.
MICHELE GOETZ: They
have supply chains.
EVREN ERYUREK: They have
systems that they run?
MICHELE GOETZ: They do.
They've got financial systems.
It's your business.
It doesn't matter.
And everybody has a vision for
where their business should go
and what those objectives are.
So build your success
story around that.
Start with where are my
business opportunities.
How is data going to
shape that for me?
Where do I want to take
my business forward?
EVREN ERYUREK: That's true.
MICHELE GOETZ: John
Deere's example
there is to push the envelope
on not just being a farming
equipment company.
They want to help you do a
better job at bringing products
to market yourself.
And recognizing-- being
real about the challenges
that you face.
Not just that you're missing
information, but really
holistically looking at
how you interact and engage
with that data and how you're
going to put it to use.
Look at the people and
processes, the experiences
around that data from
the point of bringing it
in to the point of where
it's being presented
to the point where
you're making decisions
and taking actions off of that.
Now you can start looking at
a much more holistic solution
for your data
strategies overall,
for the management of that,
and taking into account
the governance policies that
are going to happen from it.
And then it boils down to, how
do I know I did a great job?
How do I sell myself?
How do I tell that story?
How do I get that
next promotion?
It's what I do great from a
data management perspective.
What did I do great from a
data governance perspective.
And what did I do great
from a business perspective.
So you have three
different points of view.
For every stakeholder, that
is part of delivering value.
And 69% of companies
who do this,
who think from a
business-led perspective,
have data governance
programs in place.
So that doesn't look
like putting the brakes
on your business, does it?
EVREN ERYUREK: No,
they have grown.
MICHELE GOETZ: And
the way that you
start to enable and
drive culture change
around that is, how do
you know the data is good?
Where do you put in these
cues as you bring data in,
as you're going to use it?
As you distribute that
out to your customers,
you are looking at social
mechanisms that say,
I like my data.
And you see the thumbs up,
you see a star that says,
it's certified and it's
managed and it's governed well.
So I know somebody is
taking a look at it
and has a vested interest in my
personal success with the data.
And there's also cues from a
governance perspective to say,
are we hitting up
against any regulations?
Are there risks from our data?
So really thinking holistically
around those success factors
and metrics and KPIs,
and bringing that back
into the experience to
drive an appropriate culture
around that.
EVREN ERYUREK: No more reactive,
much more proactive approach.
MICHELE GOETZ: Exactly.
It's social.
EVREN ERYUREK: I know.
It is all social.
MICHELE GOETZ: Roles
and responsibilities.
Oftentimes we
think of governance
as the big bureaucracy
at the top.
And we have our
executive councils
and there's a lot
of conversation.
And then you say, what happens?
Well, now I'm going
to go fix the data.
But really what we're
doing is driving a hub
and spoke culture around this.
Having centers of gravity
where expertise about the data
and the value from the
data is going to come in.
And even looking at
that directly at the end
points of your organization.
When you said who's
creating the data,
they're stewards and custodians,
not just creationists.
They have a vested
responsibility
in ensuring that the information
that they're collecting
and bringing in not
only works for them,
but will also help drive things
and continue to pay it forward
to the rest of the organization.
So when we talk about the
experience of data and making
data work, don't
forget your end users.
Don't forget the
fact that nobody
likes to jump through 17
different applications
to figure out how to provide
customer support when somebody
has got a problem with
their insurance policy
and needs questions answered.
And, oh by the way, I've been
through that process, which
is why I explain it that way.
And when you're a
data scientist and you
want to go in and grab data and
manipulate it and prepare it,
that's great
information and insight
for the data teams
coming back where
they have to now interpret
and deploy those models
and rationalize them
against policies.
So building a mechanism
for tribal knowledge
to come through is
what we talk about when
we say a change in culture
and bringing data governance
to the edge of your business.
Now what happens?
You need an awesome
delivery team to do that.
Who's going to instrument
across infrastructure, your data
sources, and your end
points, from applications
to devices to automation?
We need engineering
and DataOps right
within our chief data office.
They are the
masters of delivery,
building the services
and the pipelines that
are going to deliver--
taking, just like
John Deere did,
those data governance
requirements and data
requirements, mashing
them together,
and really thinking succinctly
about where that drives
into the solutions that happen.
EVREN ERYUREK: The
chief data officer
that you saw is a trend.
If you look at the next
18 months, last 18 months,
there's a huge tick.
And you're going to
actually see that continuing
because everybody is trying
to figure out what their data
strategy is, and they're trying
to build their organization
around it.
MICHELE GOETZ: Exactly.
EVREN ERYUREK: And each of
those chief data officers
are coming with
the mindset of, OK,
what do I do to get more
value out of my data?
That's exactly the organization
they're trying to establish.
I am willing to bet
some of you are already
in those organizations today.
MICHELE GOETZ: Exactly.
And you need that
strategic leader
because the complexity
around this,
not only in terms
of what you want
to aspire to with your data,
but how you operationalize that,
not just from team and delivery,
but holistically your program
has to come out.
Look at all these
different processes that
are driving towards
outcomes, managing
around both offensive and
defensive responsibilities,
taking into account
today, more and more,
especially as GDPR
and CCPA have on
and security breaches
are at record levels,
security is brought
into the fold.
It doesn't just sit
over here anymore.
When you're moving into
more complex data science
and artificial
intelligence capabilities,
you are now tapping
into historical archives
of your data, turning cold
storage into hot storage.
What is the life cycle of that?
How do manage there?
EVREN ERYUREK: Could
you have used that data
that was sitting there?
MICHELE GOETZ: Right.
EVREN ERYUREK: Do you actually
know the lineage of your data?
Do you know if you can
actually use that data?
Do you have the process
to identify all those?
MICHELE GOETZ: Exactly.
And so creating those policies
of recognizing what they are,
communicating them,
training the organization
to do that, all these different
policies are resolving
themselves around those
outcomes and objectives
that you're looking at,
both from a data governance
point-of-view, as well as
your business policies,
as well as regulatory
and risk management.
EVREN ERYUREK: Did
you see some instances
where some good dynamic policy
investments and companies are
really actually integrating
into their business practices?
MICHELE GOETZ: So.
EVREN ERYUREK: Have you, maybe.
MICHELE GOETZ: I
think the oil and gas
industry is amazing in the way
that they think about this.
It's very complicated on
drawing oil out of the ground.
So if you think about the
complexity of their partner
ecosystem to just build the
drill to put down the well,
and then run all of the
management and maintenance off
of that, handling
inventory and parts,
they really operationalize
the data to the tasks.
And so those policies have
to balance against things
like trusted networks
to share information,
ensuring that parts aren't
coming from the black market
and really are to spec and
who they've purchased from
so they don't have a drill
go down and lose $1 million
an hour.
So you can really see where
policies, business policies,
risk policies are all brought
together just to bring oil
to market.
Or energy, I mean,
energy is the same thing.
If you're on electric
cars, the same.
EVREN ERYUREK: [INAUDIBLE]
about the distribution.
MICHELE GOETZ: Exactly.
So policies are really coming
together in that manner, too.
How do you deal
with the complexity?
Oh my goodness, tech has
go to take care of it.
EVREN ERYUREK: Automation?
Somehow we've got to
automate these things?
MICHELE GOETZ:
Somehow, some way.
Without giving you
too much credence,
you need a Google in the
center of your environment.
And why do I say that?
We think of data and
how you manage it
around this notion of metadata.
How do we describe
our information,
how do we set policies
around that information,
how do we see ownership
for that data,
and where is it located
what's the lineage of it.
EVREN ERYUREK: It's [? double ?]
vary your data assets are
to begin with, right?
MICHELE GOETZ:
The first thing we
do is profile our
information and capture
all of that metadata.
What does that metadata
mean for us though
is the bigger question.
And so then our governance
processes come in
and what do we do?
We slap a glossary on top of it.
So that we put it
into business context.
Now we've got an awesome
data governance program
where data governance
and data management
are all coming together.
And we'll figure out how to
connect all of our systems
and make our services
and pipelines flow.
And we should be off and
running to the races,
and we're all set.
But in the world where we
have to change the experience,
where democratizing data
is much more important
than it was in the past,
where data engineers don't
stop at bringing
data into a data lake
or into another
type of repository,
but they have to think
about that delivery,
they have to think about
presentation of information,
you need a marketplace.
What does that
marketplace look like?
So catalogs today
start to become
that center of the universe,
of not just describing
the physical, logical, and
semantic aspects of the data,
not just housing all
of those policies
and ownerships and practices,
but also becoming that point,
both from services, as well as
direct access to information.
So that you have--
and I hate to say it,
we're back to a
knowledge center, guys.
Don't twitch if
you remember Lotus.
EVREN ERYUREK: That's
part of the knowledge.
MICHELE GOETZ: It's so much
smarter because machine
learning is at the heart of it.
EVREN ERYUREK: Exactly.
MICHELE GOETZ: So
all those social
cues that we talked
about earlier,
you can see what
people are sharing.
You can see what
people like, you
can see what people
are changing,
you can see what people are
saying about information.
And that's not just on
the consumption side--
that's your governance teams,
and that's your data management
and engineering teams as well.
So it's really important
to think about,
how do you bring together the
metadata facet, the business
glossary facet,
and the marketplace
and engagement,
and build services
that are not just about an
ETL job or a streaming job.
But look at the queries
that are running
against your information.
Look at the Python and R
scripts that are coming out
of your data science notebooks.
All of that information really
helps you understand not only
what data you have and
how it can be used,
but where it's providing value.
And this is my
English muffin slide.
I like talking about
the nooks and crannies
of where data lives.
Don't just think that
that metadata is only
in your databases.
It's everywhere.
Let's go back to the
John Deere situation.
How do you manage master data?
Is that in an MDM environment?
It could be a Kafka topic.
Now you're distributing all of
these definitions and models
about your data across
every piece of technology.
Your catalogs have
to be able to profile
and understand and interpret and
synchronize that information.
It's really
critical-- this is how
you can navigate your fabrics.
This is how you have the
appropriate oversight.
EVREN ERYUREK: Don't just
think about your apps
and what the data
is flowing through.
Think about the assets,
think about new containers
that you're managing.
Think about all the
servers that your data
might be running through.
You really have to consider
all that in your system.
MICHELE GOETZ: Get started
with it on a smaller basis.
Think about your solution,
think about the pipeline first.
Begin there so that
you're continuously
accumulating this
information and starting to--
I don't know if there are
any gamers in the room?
When you've got your game map
open and it's all highlighted
and you see a big light
in the section of the map
that you're in your
universe, and then
as you move around the
map starts to open up.
OK, not a lot of gamers here.
EVREN ERYUREK: No, no so much.
MICHELE GOETZ: Sorry.
But everything
becomes illuminated
as you move through.
And that's what your
catalog should be
able to do and help you with.
It should start
illuminating iteratively
through your data ecosystems.
Lessons learned.
EVREN ERYUREK: Go ahead.
What did we learn?
MICHELE GOETZ: One
size does not fit all.
Your data has to fit the
experience and the policies
and procedures and culture
of your organization.
It can drive massive
benefits when you tie it
to those business outcomes--
hopefully driving
income-- to deliver.
There is a certain
amount of centralization
in the organization
that is required.
Somebody needs to
have and has a purview
over the entire landscape.
That's really where
that chief data officer
comes in and drives some
of the top-down priorities
and objectives for
your data, as well
as making sure that the
bottom-up is orchestrated
appropriately.
That's a tough job.
It's complex from an
operations perspective,
as well as from the
data perspective.
It requires that
different approach
to empower the enterprise,
that notion of tribal knowledge
and tribal contribution to get
that governance and culture out
into the edge and
bring that back in.
EVREN ERYUREK: And there
will be multiple tools.
Don't be really
locked into, I got
to have one tool
that does everything.
There will be multiple
services that you're
going to put together.
Think about the flexibility, try
to solve it around the problem
that you have in hand.
Pull one thread all
the way out, and see
what we can actually do.
MICHELE GOETZ: Exactly.
And so measure it based
off of the IT objectives,
the governance objectives,
and the business objectives.
And that's ensuring that you're
striking the right balance
between what is the value
your data is bringing, as well
as protecting you on
the back end from risk.
EVREN ERYUREK: And don't think
governance as compliance only.
It's an enabler for
you, what you're
going to be doing with those
capabilities for your business.
A few things we're
doing today on Google.
We actually announced just
about all these things,
so I can talk about it now.
Some of you may have been
using our Cloud DLP services.
Know where your data is.
You heard about our
programs yesterday, Anthos.
And you can actually
use it on your
on prem, hybrid
facilities, or in GCP.
This is your data
loss prevention.
This is a fantastic
tool for those of you
who are concerned about masking
the data that should not
be seen by others.
You can actually train it.
You've been possibly
using it today.
We announced our metadata
management cloud Data Catalog.
This is a capability
that actually
helps for you to
discover your assets,
metadata wherever
your data might be.
And it's a capability
that you can
integrate with other tools
that are available on-site.
It might be on-prem
tools that you're
using through the
metadata exchange
that you can actually
achieve some of these things.
These are all there
for you to discover.
On top of it, you
can build some policy
management systems,
access control
systems that you can build.
You have an integrated
identity access management
that I am sure many of you
have been using already today
that helps you identify,
create those policies.
Types of personas, we can
have what type of data
access where and
when and how long.
These are all things
that you can do today.
We have a very
aggressive roadmap
to really drive what
we can help you with.
There's a lot of things
that we can provide you
around the principles of
who can access to what data.
Many of you have
come to us and said,
hey, I'm dealing with this
thing and here are my PII data.
I don't want anyone in my
organization to have access,
but I want my analysts
to be able to do it.
But just mask that data
because it has PII data.
I don't want to
lose sight of that.
But only those people who have
access can actually control it.
So we are providing
those capabilities.
And there is of
course table levels.
There is of course
the role levels.
There's a lot of things in here.
There's retention policies
that you want to run,
or deletion policies
that you want to run.
Those are all part
of our roadmaps
that we're talking
about in here.
And we will be able
to really provide you
administrative tools
that helps you, gives
you knobs that you can
actually provide solutions
within your organizations,
because you need those to be
able to drive your policies
within your organization,
around your business
just as it fits for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]